we weren't looking for another reason to
love Tom Hanks but he just gave us one
more an eight-year-old Australian boy
who was being bullied because his name
is Corona wrote Tom a letter and told
him all about it so what did Tom do well
he wrote him back he said I'm a friend
of him and I'm gonna write back soon
Tom sent corona a typewritten letter of
encouragement and the corona brand
typewriter that he wrote it on about
that Tom Hanks well you know Tom
definitely has a lot to be grateful for
today because he and wife Rita Wilson
are celebrating 32 years of marriage we
got married for all the right reasons
I really like him and he likes me and
and we laugh a lot according to our et
source Tom and Rita are spending the day
together drinking some wine and cooking
dinner as they continue to social
distance quote experiencing kovat
nineteen together was life-changing
an illness that could have killed one or
both of them has made them truly
appreciate the life they have built yes
their love story is one for the ages Tom
told me
Rita first caught his eye at 16 years
old here's the story I did an episode of
the Brady began in 1984 when they
co-starred in the comedy volunteers do
you mean you've just been trying to go
to bed with me well I think I put in the
hours don't you I did meet her on a film
Rita Wilson who's her name the men are
volunteers we've been going out for two
of them almost two and a half years
by the time we interviewed Hanks for his
1988 blockbuster big they were days away
from walking down the aisle I thought I
loved this woman six months ago but I
loved her even more now so it just keeps
changing all the time
I can't imagine Tom Hanks as a husband
pretty pretty scary thought is I thought
I was a pretty good boyfriend so I guess
make a pretty good husband Rita a
first-generation daughter to Greek
immigrant parents could relate to the
film she produced in 2002 My Big Fat
Greek Wedding when I don't I'm going to
get married you have two more weeks and
then get rid of him during et's 35 years
with a couple we've picked up on some of
their secrets to a happy marriage first
their attraction is still on fire this
is one of the most classically beautiful
women who's ever walked the planet earth
again believe she's married inmate
looking good and of course Tom isn't
afraid to release a few man tears while
publicly declaring his love I think this
was the luckiest woman in the world
tonight when you said what you did a
lover that is so close to fine we should
all be able to experience such heaven
right here on earth
everybody should be so lucky with their
lover Tom and Rita have overcome so much
together in 2015 their bond was tested
when she was diagnosed with breast
cancer I would say that we got closer if
it's even possible to say that my wife
can beat anything she is superhuman she
doesn't have the other shield or the
golden lasso
but my wife can jump through hoops that
are smaller and bigger than I can only
imagine
[Music]